en el diagrama que se muestra abajo el
cuadrilátero
efe gh este de aquí fue obtenido
mediante una secuencia de
transformaciones en el cuadrilátero
abc p y después nos dicen la información
que ya está escrita aquí el ángulo a
mide 69 grados el ángulo b es de 102
grados el ángulo g es de 145 grados y la
medida del ángulo h es 44 grados cuando
en los siguientes datos adicionales es
suficiente para concluir que las únicas
transformaciones realizadas fueron
traslación es rotaciones reflexiones y
dilataciones y ningún otro tipo de
transformaciones dicho de otra manera si
solamente utilizamos traslación es
rotaciones reflexiones y dilataciones
quiere decir que estas dos figuras son
semejantes y si este es el caso estamos
viendo
en caso de ser
am
estamos viendo cuadriláteros semejantes
dicho de otro modo cuál de estos hechos
ya sea el primero o el segundo o ambos o
ninguno cuáles de estos hechos son
suficientes para poder determinar que
estos dos cuadriláteros son semejantes
la cual es otra manera de decir que se
puede ir de uno a otro solamente
utilizando traslación es rotaciones
reflexiones y dilataciones entonces
veamos a este primero este primer set de
hechos que está aquí nos dice que el
ángulo se mide 145 grados así que nos
dice que aquí son 145 grados
lo voy a escribir 145 grados aquí y nos
dicen que la medida del ángulo
es 69 grados nos dicen que este es
69 grados entonces con esta información
sabemos que para cada uno de los
cuadriláteros sabemos tres de los
ángulos y tenemos que averiguar y porque
ya sabemos tres de ellos podemos obtener
el cuarto lo podemos obtener porque la
suma de los ángulos en un cuadrilátero
debe de sumar 360 grados
entonces si queremos averiguar el valor
del ángulo
efe de aquí sería podemos decir que es x
que sería x más 69 grados más 145 grados
más 44 grados es igual a 360 grados
así que saquemos la calculadora x deberá
de ser 360 es menos esto de aquí
entonces sería 360 menos 69 menos 145
244 menos 44 son 102 grados entonces
este ángulo de aquí es de 102 grados
entonces démonos cuenta estos dos ya
tienen tres ángulos en común tienen uno
de sesenta y nueve grados
déjenme resaltarlo este ángulo de aquí
me de 69 igual que éste veamos ahora
este este ángulo de aquí me de 102
grados igual que éste y ahora nos
movemos al ángulo siguiente es de 145
grados pues corresponde a este 145
grados y si conocemos tres de los
ángulos sabemos que este último este de
aquí el cuarto deberá de ser de 44
grados
podemos tomar 360 y restar
145 102 y 69 y vas a obtener 44 grados
vas a obtener 44 grados 44 grados
entonces tenemos dos cuadriláteros donde
todos estos ángulos son congruentes
entre ellos
si tienes estas dos figuras y todos sus
ángulos correspondientes son congruentes
entre ellos entonces sabes que son
semejantes y si sabes que son semejantes
sabes que puedes ir de uno a otro
solamente utilizando una combinación de
traslación es que esto es simplemente
moviéndolo en dos dimensiones rotaciones
rotando lo alrededor de algún punto
reflejando lo lo que podría ser
simplemente volteándolo con respecto a
una línea o dilatando lo lo que sería
aumentarle la escala o disminuyendo la
entonces la primera es definitivamente
esta es definitivamente buena veamos la
segunda también
independientemente puede determinar que
estos dos son semejantes
entonces lo que voy a hacer es limpiar
esta zona para tener espacio para
trabajar déjenme borrarla
déjenme borrar esto de aquí y
reflexionemos acerca de lo que este
segundo hecho nos está diciendo
este nos dice que la medida del ángulo
de es 44 grados que éste es de 44 grados
y que la medida del ángulo efe 102
grados es de 102 grados entonces una vez
más nos han dado un ángulo más en cada
uno y desde este punto podemos averiguar
el último ángulo entonces si sabes todos
los ángulos en dos cuadriláteros
tú puedes determinar si son semejantes
serán semejantes solos y sólo si todos
los ángulos correspondientes
si tienes cuatro ángulos
correspondientes que son congruentes
entre ellos entonces este hecho y es
bueno déjenme mostrárselos para no solo
decir que es suficiente
calculemos este último ángulo de aquí
saquemos nuestra calculadora será 360
menos 102 menos 145 menos 44 menos 44 lo
que nos da 69 grados entonces este de
aquí es de 69 grados
entonces no tenemos que son 102 grados
luego 69 grados 44 grados 102 grados 69
grados 44 grados entonces este último
deberá ser de 145 grados
justo como este si tres ángulos son los
mismos el cuarto deberá de ser el mismo
entonces este ángulo corresponde a este
ángulo este ángulo corresponde a ese
ángulo y finalmente este ángulo
corresponde a ese ángulo siendo los
cuadriláteros los cuatro ángulos
interiores son congruentes corresponden
uno al otro entonces deberán de ser
semejantes por lo que puedes ir de uno
al otro a través de traslación es
rotaciones reflexiones y dilataciones
entonces
también es correcta de hecho cualquiera
de estas dos es suficiente para poder
concluir que las únicas transformaciones
utilizadas fueron estas entonces yo
elegiría la opción de las dos respuestas
son correctas